goldie you said of all the girls you've
had uh you could play the magical mrs
claus
the rest of your life so what made this
role so special for you
because she has like endless potential
as a character
um because she can do a lot of things
she's magical she's
she's a savior in many ways she healed
you know one of our dear dear you know
their family member
and she also can see uh what's going on
she's
she has vision and and i like that so i
i think she
that she'd be endlessly interesting to
to replicate
uh new aspects of this character that
called murders is like having
all the cameras in the world isn't it
yeah
look at anything for the cauldron i can
there's no i mean
not many people would have any secrets
it's kind of like kind of like
facebook helps you understand why why
santa knows
if you've been bad or good yeah
um i was just talking to tyreese gibson
and he was saying how much he loved
overboard and that one of the big
reasons why he wanted to be a part of
this movie
was because he knows you hadn't worked
together since that film and he just
wanted to be a part of this reunion for
you both
so how special was it getting to work
together
that was great i mean first of all i got
to work with tyrese three times
i'd like to work with goalie at least
you know we got this is the fifth time
we worked together actually
we had a blast it's great to go to work
in in the morning together great to
bring it home at night
and have a few of a daily rehash
um which we laugh about over some great
mushroom soup that this hotel had
and uh and have a drink and and then and
then enjoy your life together and then
go back
go back at it again in the morning and
we went shopping yeah we bought you
together we went to the market we had a
great time it was in vancouver
uh and we got made up together and we
had one trailer
and i make up people who have been with
us for many many years there's a lot of
history in that
in that trailer we had a lot of fun oh
this sounds like the dream job for you
both
it was it was yeah it really was i mean
at this time in your life as an actor
too
um it's fun to find roles
that you're really right for and and
this i i really believe that it is true
that these
these roles are perfectly matched for
who we are
okay not to put you on the spot but you
both have said that humor is a key to
your relationship so who do you think's
the funnier one
that's a safe answer that's really funny
i mean
you know we have funny kids yes i know
you do
there's big laughs i mean goldie i love
to hear goldie laugh
when when she's laughing about something
it's just it just uh you know
it reverberates throughout the whole
house and it's a great that's a great
feeling
i love that all right well speaking of
the holidays what would you say
are your favorite family traditions any
movies that you have to watch every year
oh that's interesting we're too busy
doing other things
i mean we don't watch a lot i don't
watch a lot of movies
not not it's a bit very busy we've got
lots of kids and stuff and things are
going on and christmas
skiing there's stuff there's outside i
mean
we're you know we don't watch a lot of
the movies now the kids might watch some
movies you know they they might have a
better answer
uh but we're you know we're
orchestrating a lot of stuff at
christmas we're busy
well you're trying so great getting
keep going keep going you're trying to
find out
behind everybody's back what so-and-so
really wants or needs or
you know so yeah a lot of uh yeah so did
they see something is there anything
there
i mean i don't know it's so stumped i
don't know what mommy really wants
oh that's great and it makes you feel
good because it takes the pressure off
of the fact that you feel so horrible
that you're not finding something that
you know would be great you want it you
don't want you want to come through at
christmas time
yeah it's true there's a bit of pressure
i know it's true well thank you so much
for this movie i think so many people
especially this year are needing a film
just like this so thanks again
merry christmas
you